here on the mercedes-benz vans phone
line is a man who's got a new gig to go
along with his other new gig how many
new gigs can one man have well uh greg
olsen uh one of the the best analysts on
tv i i've told him this the last time i
really enjoy his calls of nfl games on
fox along with former uh carolina
panther and so many other places ryan
khalil and vince vaughn they have formed
a
a new podcasting company called
audiorama and here to talk about that
and everything else is the
aforementioned greg olsen on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line how are
you greg
i'm doing great rich how's it going man
it's good to be on i'm doing fine so um
how'd you get this
did khalil put you in touch with vince
vaughn mr hollywood is that how that
worked greg is that the comments
actually actually for for for once it
was actually the other way around so i
got to know vince i got to know vince
when i lived out in chicago we got
connected through some mutual friends
the bears playing time when he was still
living out there and kind of struck up a
friendship and got to know him and his
family and and now him and khalil
actually live back in manhattan beach um
you know their neighbors back there so
just all of us have just kept you know
obviously been good friends for a long
time now and the two of them met just
through me and our and our friendship
with each other and we were having
dinner um actually about this time last
year out in manhattan beach we were just
having dinner and i was kind of pitching
them on this youth sports podcast which
is now you know the you think show that
we've launched and
i was kind of pitching the most idea i
had about like this world i'm living in
with youth sports and you know the
decisions that all these parents have to
make and here i am i've lived this my
whole life i grew up around it with my
dad being my coach and it's hard for me
to understand what's enough what's not
enough what i said i can only imagine
what this must be like for other
families like there has to be a show
here where like we go out and we have
these conversations and we explore all
these different sides of this crazy
world of youth sports and um
and they're like dude we love it but
like don't give that to someone else
like why don't we just build our own
platform around it you know between
their contacts out there in hollywood
with the scripted stuff and the shows
and um you know we were able to bring in
a really cool venture capital group that
was behind wondering and some of the
work they did with um
with powerhouse capital so we just
formed a really great group of guys that
really understand this space and uh you
think will be our first you know kind of
launch show and we're looking to
continue to add content and that really
interesting storytelling and other uh
and other pieces of content around it as
we continue to grow the platform so it's
been it's been a lot of work but it's
been a lot of fun so my bad it's
khalil's in the side car on this one
and i hope so
listening okay well we all we we love
calling ryan khalil out we love we love
smoking him out we love him he's doing
some awesome stuff right now i mean he's
in brooklyn right now filming a show for
apple i mean he's doing like real deal
work here well uh i love it i just think
it's terrific um so congratulations on
that we'll talk a little bit more about
it before uh we send you on with your
your good thursday um what did you make
of the russell wilson seattle
um
trade with denver what do you think of
that greg olsen
you know i i don't want to say i'm
surprised i mean i was i shouldn't say i
was surprised that it actually ended up
i don't surprise i was not surprised
that those rumors had been have been
around and you know usually where
there's smoke there's fire right i mean
it just seemed like there was a little
that something was coming to an end that
there was a new kind of changing of the
guard going on there and and you know no
mistake that russ wanted to be somewhere
where it was an offensive driven league
and it was an offensive driven you know
team and the system and whatnot it was
just a matter of
would seattle ever part ways with a
franchise quarterback and someone like
russ who's kind of such a key figure in
that organization's history and
has you know won a super bowl and you
know it's kind of the one of the marquee
players in the league so
you know when the news broke yesterday i
got a couple texts from some buddies and
they're like rusty's traded i was like
what but i think it makes sense to
denver i think denver was one of those
spots that all along always seemed like
a spot that was a quarterback away from
being the contender so i there's not
always a lot of those situations but i
feel like denver was one of them you
could say indianapolis was one of them
i'm sure for denver getting him out of
the nfc was a big factor in sending him
to denver so
i think it doesn't surprise me i think
he can go there and win i think that
roster i think it's going to be an
offensive driven system with hackett
coming from green bay
and obviously they have some weapons
offensively they got some young pieces
so i think it checks a lot of the boxes
that he's looking for and listen with
his no trade clause if he if he wasn't
on board he would have he wouldn't have
accepted the trade so it seems like this
was something
all parties were were on board with and
that's usually how things get worked out
right so where do you stand on the fact
that he's uh uh you know entering his
mid-30s and for the first time missed
some games last year
uh his mvp season the year before
fizzled out
um and that that denver's not getting
the russell wilson
that uh we all came to know and that
seattle came to love what are your
thoughts on that great i just think
we've seen so many quarterbacks and we
still see it this day with rogers and
brady and you know we saw brees play at
a high level for you know for a long
time and i just think we're we see
quarterbacks play
well into their 30s you know mid to late
30s and you know 40s with with rot with
uh
with brady so i just think
you know with the guy just being around
russ and seeing how he prepares and how
he takes care of his body and the team
he has around him that you know he you
talk about a guy who is fully committed
to his craft and fully committed to his
offseason you know there's no difference
with him the day before a playoff game
or in february training at his place
where he built the weight room and built
a football field at his house in san
diego and i mean he has he's he's no
he's experiencing no expense he's not
cutting any corners i mean he's gonna be
one of those guys that is taking care of
his body at it at an everyday all the
day type basis um all the time type
basis and you know i just think he's a
guy that can play he's been vocal about
he thinks he can play you know past 40
and i think he has a lot of things that
he still wants to accomplish so i don't
think i'd be concerned about his age i
don't think that's
that's right now he's entering the part
where that's a factor but um i think i
still think he's got a good amount of
ball left in him physically and and
mentally he's about you know he's very
strong and very passionate about what he
does greg olsen here on the rich eisen
show
and then you know there's the wence
acquisition to washington um i'll be
honest you know
your washington commander fan and you're
hearing well they're taking a shot at
rogers they took a shot at ross they've
taken shots everywhere it's wence's gig
now
uh i wouldn't be terribly excited about
it uh are you
you know i think there's two two aspects
to it i think you mentioned i think
washington and i've known ron and i've
known a lot of those guys for a long
time you know they understood i mean
heineke was a great story he's a great
kid gave them some really good play
brought a lot of energy to the group but
they they all understood that at some
point they needed to make you know they
tried to bring in fitzpatrick last year
he ended up getting banged up early
which made you know made taylor play
but
i just think at some point they realized
they needed to get better at that
position and get a marquee guy in there
get some stability and you know it's
most likely not going to come in the
draft it's mostly going to have to be a
free agent that they either trade for
either a free agent they can sign
or someone you know they tried to trade
for stafford they tried to make a russet
you know make a run at russ and
you know i don't so much think that
settling on
wence was the big issue i just the part
that i was that concerns me is that they
pay his whole salary
so i think they kind of let indianapolis
who you knew had pretty much given up on
indianapolis i'd be curious about how
the conversation went
when you know a team has to dump their
quarterback because they've already in
essence made that clear that they're
going in a different direction after
just one short year
you you thought that maybe indy you've
seen teams in the past eat some of the
salary of the big guy to try to get them
off their own books and carry some of
that cost if they could have gotten went
at a reduced value because it was being
offset by indianapolis i think it would
the whole trade would be looked at a
little differently so i think right now
absorbing that you know was it 28
million dollars that's a big number for
a guy that you know we saw play well at
times last year but the mark was always
can he play well enough when it matters
and ended up falling short in the
playoffs so i think
i i think that's a big gamble i think
it's interesting he's very talented i
think we've seen him when he plays well
he plays really well he's just got to
find a way to to not have the you know
the
down moments right the tough moments
kind of sometimes outshine the the
positives and
when you're making 28 million and now
you're on your third team there's gonna
be a big spotlight on them and
obviously washington feels like they can
get the best out of them
greg olsen here on the rich eisen show
um greg is your content creator uh of
note now um
the uh best ideas sometimes are just
spitballed
we had one on on this show just the
other day we have a new segment or idea
we'll see it's still in this infancy
face we don't have any uh a venture
capital behind it yet um but it's the
tb12 heat check
uh on a scale of zero to twelve zero is
he's eating frozen pizzas at craft
services with jane fonda taking five
right uh no chance of him coming back 12
is him definitely coming back where do
you stand on a tb-12 heat check here
on the thursday before the night
you're gonna have sponsor you're gonna
have sponsors lined up to sponsor that
segment any day i can sense it uh we can
make we can make a podcast out of it for
audio rama we could do that done i would
love let's let's talk offline
we are always looking to get great
storytellers because we're happy to take
you sounds good okay we'd be we'd be
honored um
i'd put him at a
seven
50 right i'm not a math major but let's
just call that 50 50. right i think he's
a little shade on the positive i think
that's that's my take i don't know what
that's based on
i don't know if that's based in reality
or if that's based on just all of us
football fans hoping he's not done
uh maybe some false optimism but
i uh i would go with a seven well you
have experience on
leaving football playing behind um but
also trying to extend your career as
long as possible
you you know had injuries that that uh
obviously factored in and brady
from all you know
uh you know evidence right now doesn't
appear to be hurt in any way shape or
form as a matter of fact he looks
just like tom brady um
so you have that uh i think insight and
him just leaving a door open
um
why why does he need to do that it's uh
other than that he's just being honest
about it i think yeah i think that's
what it is i think he's just being
honest and and i think you know there's
there's two ways of thinking about it i
think traditionally the way people view
it is you know if you're not all the way
in and you're not and you're and you
ain't been considering retirement then
it's time to step away right it can only
be done if you're all in and i think
there is some truth to that but i think
for a lot of guys and i know i was this
way and again i'm not going to speak for
tom but
for guys that have really poured a lot
of their life into this there's also the
element is of
if there's a little itch left to play
you don't ever want regret right you
don't want to ever feel like you walked
away when you had more left and when i
think about the way my career ended as
you said you know my last couple years i
had that foot problem
in 17 and 18 and then i was healthy and
19 and felt really good going into the
season and then you know came back for
one more year and 20 and felt good and
felt healthy and had no injuries from
the year before and had a great
offseason what not then i ended up
hurting my other foot which was
beyond frustrating
but like after 2020 i was like i'm done
you know what i mean like i i got it all
out of my system i had no second
thoughts i didn't even consider it i
think for a lot of guys people always
think of it to me backwards i think as
long as there's that little bit of
that life left a little bit of that itch
a little bit of that that motivation and
passion to continue to pursue this
at a high level it's very hard for guys
to just completely slam that door when
they can sit there and be very honest
with themselves and reflect and say
man part of me i can still do this and
what you don't want to happen every
player's biggest
you know fear
is that they leave the game and a couple
years later they sit back and they say
what if what if i gave it another year
what if i gave it one more shot did i
leave right and i think that and again
i'm not saying that's what's happening
with tom i'm just saying i could
understand that mentality which is why
as you said he's kind of always alluded
to leaving this door open he's never
really completely slammed it shut and
and from that perspective i understand
the train of thought i also think you
know
i don't know if there's a what if for a
guy with already seven in the case um
it could be you know you never know
because he's you have to have that greed
is good type mentality you know
but maybe it's him just seeing you know
rogers is getting that money and it's
not a money thing but just getting he's
back and you know everybody's like russ
has got the trade and he could just come
back and say it's my league guys you
know but don't forget yeah they're you
know that they could do that
absolutely the most the most successful
guys are usually the most highly
motivated and it's an internal
motivation where
they don't ever accept that anyone else
is better than them right
tom brady will whether he's 24 or 44 he
will never in his mind not be the best
and and that's just this inner fuel that
certain guys have and they channel it
and it's your greatest strength but at
times it could be your greatest weakness
because you know it's hard to move on
and you become obsessed and it's really
all you focus on and
and so i i think what you're saying is
real and again i'm speculating i've
never spoken to tom personally about it
it's hard to know what's in somebody's
mind but someone who's played at such a
high level
for such a long time he had a mvp
caliber year just this past season it's
not like we're seeing a guy at the tail
end of his career fall into the you know
fall into the abyss and just be a shell
of himself he's playing at it as good as
he ever had
that's a tough thing to just say okay
i'm done when maybe in his mind he says
i can still do this
yeah look we're not going to hold you to
it i mean it's again it's just an
original idea that we just spitballed
and there's no venture capital behind it
yet so we won't hold you to it but next
time next time you come on though uh
we'll we we now have a baseline of your
seven that's mine too i'm seven also my
my guy brockman here is uh
11.99 right you know all the way up
not going all the way to 12 just yet but
yeah gotta leave a little bit greg you
know what i mean a little wiggle room
yeah you got it that's called the hedge
you're
congrats on audio rama uh send my best
to khalil uh vince vaughn and everyone
else there and youth inc um how can
people get this just uh where all
podcasts are acquired greg that's right
yeah we're all podcaster we're all
podcasters are seen listen you go on
wherever you guys wherever anyone
listens to their pods go on and
subscribe and and listen our first two
episodes dropped yesterday we talked to
a sports psycho world-renowned sports
psychologist dr michael gervais um and
just really dove into like the real
issues that are at hand the struggles
that families and parents and kids are
having you know navigating this world we
talked with jerry rice we got some
really cool episodes coming up in the
next couple weeks with uh with cooper
manning and obviously his son has been
well chronicled the experience he's
having now and shawn johnson the olympic
gymnast and just her upbringing and her
life so it's we have some really cool
conversations on the horizon with some
real people with some really unique
insight um
we are fortunate invisalign wanted to
jump on board and kind of dive into this
together as our partner in this project
and be along with us from the jump so
it's been it's been a really cool
project and people can go and download
and subscribe wherever they get their
pods and uh we hope people enjoy uh kind
of going on this journey of
of kind of seeking out this information
alongside us love it love it let me know
when you're out here in l.a i'd love to
see you greg love to have you here i'd
love to hang out take care man thanks
again for the time always appreciate it
that's greg olsen right here um go check
out youth inc role podcasts are required
and that may just be
over the next couple weeks never know
the new lead analyst for the nfl on fox
oh
yeah there i don't know
do you know the acement stuff hasn't
been announced yet but it's there and
buck so many members
a lot of moving parts a lot of moving
parts a lot of venture capital behind
that too
oh
yes hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here